well they must have forgotten what we
are
touchdown city he throws it up into the
third
deck this is gonna be my lucky shirt
i'll send it to you i'm not gonna put
them in the dryer guys i'm going to wet
it next week
cooper ball super ball triple ball
welcome to the playoffs baby hey these
games late for everybody's game for
these leagues
just give it all you got you know what
time it is chiefs kingdom the goat tom
brady will make his 43rd appearance
in a playoff game
where else would you rather be right now
look at this
super excited to be here
lamar jackson he's either going to get
over that playoff hump or
the narrative will continue we're trying
to work we're at work right now
we just clocked in let's go up along
let's go buffalo
[Applause]
i've been waiting 18 long years for this
let's go get it done come on
championship minecraft championship
mindset won't play the time this time
last year
bruce yourself the worst team in the nfl
but look what we got now run
just on a run now make sure you go
wherever i go
whatever you got tonight i gotta have it
i need it all
nothing else in the past matters but
this moment we talked about being
warriors
one way or the other that's what you are
that's who you are that's what we are
hey once you're out let's win we don't
do it
or go home i ain't trying to go home i
ain't trying to go home damn now i ain't
trying to go home
play on football only way to do it and
they start with a horrible snap
and the browns one for the touchdown 18
years since our last playoffs
and the browns scored a defensive
touchdown
off a fumble i'm not getting off the
treadmill for the rest
of my life hardman standing in his
11-yard line drops it
puffs it bill's ball on the three-yard
line
and look at me good to be here
brady has all kinds of time close
towards the end zone touchdown
what a way to start the football game
baby we got a game in lambo they throw a
left side
on a wide receiver into the end zone
touchdown
hey that's how you handle the varsity
you smack it right in the mouth
quick talk and the rams got crosstalk
jalen ramsey
you got bird you gotta go he steps up
pocket collapsing he escapes
from our 10 five that's what we're
talking about
easy money let's go easy money
yeah yeah
[Music]
feel it baby keep it going keep on
boarding
[Music]
it's probably going to be a good couple
of weeks for folding table and picnic
benchmakers in the buffalo area
they can take they hating them t-shirts
with cabo still want to laugh at us
behaviors that we're the same old
brownies you could take time
all the way to fishing buddy you could
fish all night long
who can't win a
[Music]
[Applause]
up i'm gonna put the dagger in who throw
the bubble on ticks
big six baby yeah tana hill
steps and fires and it's intercepted
they're out there stomping on the logo
passes
[Applause]
johnson and only jackson can stop
him now too late to the end zone
touchdown the buffalo bills have all of
buffalo
rocking like they haven't been rocking
in 20-some years
always put the money on me it is
official
the chiefs will not have patrick mahomes
for the rest of this game
chad henney coming into the game if
somebody told you it was going to be
hard would you still want it
yeah yeah if the chiefs get a first down
the game's over
and he's scrambling and comes to the
near side he's at the 40
45.
[Applause]
they snap they're going for it they
flood it right
kill stays in bounds anything is
possible
packers get a score here and a two-point
conversion to get this thing tied
rogers steps up scrambles throws late
over the middle
incomplete my goodness
kick kick it wow who would have liked to
have seen them get it done there hey we
got three timeouts
i thought that they would go for it on
fourth down
no penalties take care of the ball good
routes good cause
everything do you have a play in your
playbook that will secure a first down
on a victory
god when running to the
who's that goal tom brady i really look
up to you too man
man keep your head up what a season by
cleveland getting here
another hearts broken today but they're
not the same old browns anymore
that's the most important thing right
there
good luck man go get another one this
is the proudest i've been of this team
in almost
30 years i'm off to the store
because i need ice cream chocolate ice
cream
you can't help but wonder as we watch
drew brees walk off this football field
is this the final time that we're going
to watch drew do this
tampa bay buccaneers are going to be the
first team ever
to host a super bowl
it's a ceremony yeah second ceremony
i'm new to this man we're coming home
and we're coming home to win
we still ain't played our best yet nope
we doing again baby
i'm back back-to-back afc titles
[Applause]
tampa bay
tonight tommy if you're watching
which i know you're not we're coming for
you in two weeks
no more stuck on ears no more i don't
want nobody calling us
[ __ ] ears anymore